what do all of these things have in
common protein today I want to talk to
you guys about how you can grow protein
in your garden
[Music]
hey friends it's Jen at the sunshine
farm this year I am planting a lot of
new varieties and one thing I'm really
trying to jump into is planting protein
so things like beans and lentils and
peas and soy even quinoa and spinach
have a lot of protein so I'm planting
all of these things this year I'm sure
many of them won't do very well but I'm
excited for the future that all of these
things will mean whether it's making
things like homemade soy milk or grains
like quinoa and amaranth I'm even trying
rice this year even potatoes are packed
with protein so I'm really excited about
all these things we're growing because I
think there's just such a common
misconception that if your plant-based
or if you're vegan or vegetarian that
you need to get protein we actually as
Americans get a whole lot more protein
than we really need and Chris and I have
never had an issue with protein but
nonetheless I really want to show you
guys how you can actually get a lot of
really nutritious plant-based protein in
the garden and I'm excited to share this
with you so let's just talk about a few
of the things we're growing this year
I'm going to show you at the end
planting one of these things in the
garden today and I also have some little
seedlings coming up right now that I'm
really looking forward to and I'll show
you guys those as well so let's go ahead
and get started so what proteins are we
planning on growing in the garden
the first is peas and lentils these guys
are in the same family we have some door
snow peas and I already planted these
guys just a couple weeks ago and I'm
just waiting for them to come on up
we're also doing lentils and so we're
doing two different kinds of lentils
Spanish Brown and French green and these
guys are heirloom seeds they do better
in cooler climates we actually should
have some success growing them here
because our summers don't get all that
hot but we're gonna see it's totally a
trial year with lentils and if they
don't grow well then maybe I'll just
have to barter lentils for things like
soy from somebody
so many across the country so lentils
are great source of protein lentils make
an amazing base for a soup I'm really
looking forward to this and I'm excited
to try all sorts of different ways to
cook and prepare lentils a couple
different grains that were growing that
have protein in them and I believe rice
does as well but I didn't grab that one
from my seat collection so we are
growing amaranth
this year and we're also growing quinoa
these two crops you generally have to go
a fair amount of in order to actually
get a decent harvest but I hope
eventually that we can really just
expand our garden space that we can do
that that we can plant tons of quinoa
and tons of amaranth and really have
enough grains for for Chris and I and
future kiddos that might join the family
we have peas so far we have lentils Lee
of amaranth and we have quinoa and an
even growing rice let's talk about a
couple more things that I'm growing
things that are packed with protein and
you probably know where I'm going with
this one beans beans are a great source
of protein and super good for you a lot
of people think that beans can be hard
in the digestive system there's actually
a way that you can do you can sprout
legumes before cooking them or preparing
them for a meal and they're much easier
on the digestive system that way we're
also doing soybean soy bean has a bad
rap kind of like potatoes right because
they're just thought of as lacking a lot
of nutrition I think a lot of this isn't
from the soy itself but actually the way
we grow it here in the u.s. we tend to
grow GMO soy bean in organically mass
production and we're growing things
varieties that are not matching the way
the crop was initially designed so I'm
really excited because I'm growing
soybeans here heirloom organic soybeans
and I think they're going to be really
different in terms of how they affect
our health and just the amount of
nutrients in those soy because if you
think about it plants absorb nutrients
from the soil so if you are filling your
soil with a lot of nutrients and you're
treating your soil well those plans are
going to be much healthier and packed
with a lot more nutrients so you're
going to see a big difference in terms
the tofu that you might by the store or
tofu that you make at home with
homegrown soybean now on top of the
black beans and the soybean we're also
growing all different kinds of beans
this one right here is scarlet Ember
it's a pull runner bean and it climbs as
it grows and it's just beautiful so you
can eat it as green beans or you can let
the pods dry out and you can cook up the
beans later a couple more fun things to
share with you guys
spinach spinach is a great source of
protein and iron and all sorts of
wonderful things I just direct seeded
some spinach a few days ago so hoping it
comes up soon it can be a tricky crop to
grow because it likes cool weather and
so if your spring jumps to summer really
quick you can have a hard time with
spinach but there's actually a variety
of spinach called Asian spinach that can
handle warmer temperatures so if you're
looking for the goodness of spinach but
you don't have the cool weather and you
don't have a long enough spring or fall
try Asian spinach maybe it works for you
guys and the last thing I'm so excited
about peanuts now we have two different
peanuts we're trying out this year and
peanuts are traditionally thought of as
a southern crop because they really like
heat but here in New York we have a
company's called fruition seeds that
works to adapt crops to the northern
climate and really test things out in
the northern climate to make sure that
they work before selling them to
consumers so these are two varieties
that I got ahold of from that wonderful
company and I'm really excited to grow
them these are super simple because you
just direct sow them in the ground and
then actually at the end of the season
you pull them up and the peanuts are
growing all along the roots just like
potatoes would so those are a few things
that were growing this year in terms of
protein and I'm really really excited
about it mostly because there's so many
different kinds of things and a lot of
these things I don't traditionally seen
grown in backyard gardens so I'm going
to just show you guys this one green
that we are growing that I'm really
excited about okay guys so over here our
DIY grow shelves are very empty right
now because most of the plants are
outside but I do have some starts in
here that are just coming up see these
guys right here
that is quinoa and then over here we got
some rice look at that little baby rice
I also got some a sesame Chia and
rosemary that hasn't quite come up yet
the other thing I wanted to show you
guys is this right here might not look
like a lot but it's a start
this was the soy that I saved last year
from our soy crop and I'm actually going
to be going and making some soy milk
following a recipe from one of my
favorite cookbooks called the vegan
pantry it's an amazing cookbook it's
really simple recipes all about
different staples you can make for your
home things like bread and pasta soy
milk
tempeh tofu all these things that I'm
hoping that we can make here at the
sunshine farm it's perfect if your
plant-based like we are if you're
vegetarian or vegan because a lot of
these things if you buy in the store
they're full of additives and
preservatives you're really looking for
that natural lifestyle it's so important
to be connected with the process and try
making some of these things yourself at
home so I'm gonna be making some soy
milk with this soy bean and I think we
just have enough to be able to make a
good amount this is the book I was
telling you guys about
by Miyoko I think it's Shin er Miyoko
has this amazing non-dairy cheese
company that you can get at all sorts of
grocery stores and they're not based in
coconut based cheeses and they're really
delicious guys if you have octopus
intolerance if you avoid dairy for
ethical reasons or environmental reasons
or maybe you just want to try a
healthier cheese alternative so this is
the creamy soy milk that I'm gonna be
making with our with our homegrown soy
bean I'll have to share a video all
about this later
because I might apically fail come on
outside with me let's plant some lentils
and I'll show you guys how easy it
really is to grow your own protein in
the garden right now I'm about to plant
some lentils and lentils are like peas
so you're planting them before the last
frost when it's still early spring as
soon as that ground can be worked but
the ground is not too - at that you draw
on your seeds so you can see our ground
here
is nice and wet and I've spent some time
prepping this pad to be planted it might
look a little strange but what I'm doing
here is I put all the woodchips aside to
reveal the soil underneath making sure
that I didn't mix the woodchips in with
the soil and then I dug like kind of
like just a little mini trench so I can
go ahead and plant these seeds an inch
deep in the trench this is a first-year
bed so a lot of the soil isn't nice and
aerated enough so that's why I want to
add the nice loose compost on top so
those plants have a chance to come on up
this one's a hundred days this one's 115
days we're doing French green lentils
and / Dena lentils Spanish Brown on both
of these are heirloom varieties I got
them from Annie's heirloom seeds they're
organic they're pretty cool I'm really
excited about lentils
I like lentil soup I like alts of other
lentil things I'm gonna go ahead and get
these lentils planted instead of just
having traditional grow planting I'm
gonna stagger the lentils so that I can
get more in one space so I'll show you
what I'm gonna do right now with the
French green lentils see these those
lentils looks just like what you eat
right here what I just talked about get
them very careful when you are holding
seeds you can drop them and not see
where they land luckily these aren't
carrot seeds so I can kind of see them
[Music]
whoops
walking is hard then what I'm gonna do
is in the middle between the mini rows
I'm gonna plant some beets and radishes
maybe even some carrots because those
things will mature before these lentils
are really big
well the lentils are planted they should
be coming up soon and it was so fun
talking to you guys about how to grow
plant based protein so thank you for
being here and I can't wait to share my
next video with you guys
sigh friends
[Music]